è da tutti ragazzi benvenuto che sono
video sono fra vj oggi sono consalvo che
è venuto con me a giocare a questo ciao
io mi kiamo scritto non sai come si fa
sta roba
ma gli anni alla bretella col tasto
destro distacchi la testa non è vero
quella puoi lanciare oggi un controllo
alla testa
voglio dire tutto su ora è restaurare
come faccio a donare surreale ricorda
non vorrei che giorno a testa che
scorrazza di sotto in via in via primi
bio invio a ok ho visto che l'obiettivo
è arrivare alla fine in realtà c'è la
modalità sfida quindi chi arriva prima
di vedere la modalità coop quindi quelle
cambia insieme questa è la terra cucina
gigante i tornelli che scottano ma sono
induzione questo perché faccia ma il
gioco satanica questo la scena della
vita
voglio rivedere sviluppata fino alla
morte varaita e stato bellissimo
perciò come secco e maurice manificat
chi vuole questa morabito e saltare rito
io che cosa che stiamo controllando tra
l'altro test e le teste ho capito perché
un uomo dovrebbe staccare sulla testa ma
non è un nuovo anno zombie zaia è
difficilissimo st parte veramente
difficile porti alla cavour che abbiamo
del tempo abbiamo ancora cinque minuti
mc kay sei perfetto e ha detto che
continuare stai facendo
ci sono un sacco è stato ha preso fuoco
preso fuoco c'è poi il check point sei
riuscito invece erano che la testa grado
con la testa a è chiaro jolo è un po
pubblicarla fattaci ce l'ho fatta con la
testa
sono anch'io che non ti ho detto vieni
gli ambienti aspetto aia giardino
chiaro
perché lavorare non bisogna ammazzarsi
che golf vai sto facendo i cuscinetti di
carne ne stai facendo tratto infiniti
come possibile perché sono un uomo di
sostanza che tra l'altro è servito
perché adesso hai creato la scala bravo
vieni vieni vieni dai arrivo c'è il
fidato starò insieme veramente figo
poi ci sono quasi quasi aspetto che la
testa perché il più divertente se ti
aspetta del per dischi a questo sane
apre la porta in teoria perché io vado a
ok adesso arabo c'è poi tra l'altro il
nuovo visto che c'è un mega bisteccone
gigante in mezzo alla stanza assenso o
no un cuore scuola realtà far saltare
sempre perfetto
vai grande il suicidio bellissimo viene
capito cos'è non lo so che oggi insieme
vai è vero infatti che segnava andare
insieme per forza è attento al
martellozzo dove porca lavori stop anche
se sarà addio molto mastrolindo ci ha
messo dentro si cazzisti carli tutti ho
rischiato parecchio occhio se vivo
seguito ai sono lievi il prefetto anche
in avanti
aspetto bisogna andare a casa per la
produzione diverse però in una diventare
per forza in due e dall'altra da solo ma
poi ci arrivi de oltre don t worry child
non ci credo che lei non ci posso
credere che vanta una porta sei stato un
fenomeno forse voi non ce l'avrei mai
fatta non sono mai fatto e ma non lo sa
cosa ho fatto in realtà è con ben due
minuti e 40 di scarto ragazzi metta
sotto l'aspetto ci sono dieci sospettati
aspetto se vai a dell'onore ea
dell'onore e mai perché non ci fa a
finire no già get your friends madrid i
vigili e intero misato ma [ __ ]
adesso il corpo fa il victory va avanti
si ebbe l 8 mila effetti siamo stati
bravi però me ne vorrà un po più di fini
non so se riesco edifici acquistare
queste vertice queste verso uno contro
l'altro ci segnalava bilancio ma testa
in testa quindi se uno che cos'è non lo
so ho fatto una roba abbastanza
difficile il casinò è non lo so ha detto
con shift corri non saperlo sì io siamo
invece noi siamo contro dai un barca
vice ai ayala gambula che passa la mano
si è scusato per alta non sei andato a
los angeles erano tutti per cui giocato
da lì la mia sto giappone esatta ha
giocato sulla sto morendo in
continuazione
sono ancora vivo come fai esplorativo
sono morte quando ha chiuso un occhio
letto lancio a destra una sacri frega
mai questo vi definite ok era il corpus
che per questo è veramente impossibile
che peraltro non sono finite sono 99
prova ben presente stanno a fare vai a
fuoco non c'è un banchino problema
ponente ti piace bene vai venga dato una
mano con soggetti di cui che all or die
ce la faccia a faccia fare il suo paese
si salvo si salva si no ti sei salvato
dalla sto benissimo
sei fatta vai è la prima parte l'abbiamo
fatta vieni si mantiene da apple a testa
con la testa salta no
dove stai andando no se partono
spiaccicato che sfiga perché mi sembra
possiamo neanche gli autisti io cosa ho
fatto di una gallina qua perché c'è una
gallina
c'è poi non solo fatto raggiungerlo
rabarama incredibile io sto io sto
passando sotto il passaggio sordo
incredibile jack poi anch'io da grande
siccome canzoni fatte arrivare mai sono
vivo io ho una motosega
io non ho paura di usarla paravati
aperto la strada a un bar a recco è che
non capiva cosa servisse il bottone si
fa no siamo allo stesso punto dai che
questa associazione giocare vai vai vai
se non ci posso credere quando avanti
basta lina possa volare basso a volare
ferma bottiglia ai a molti il figlio più
dove io come infatti arriveranno in una
gallina di bisogno di qui alla fine ci
sono ci sono ci sono
dovete usare le galline a come zelda e
si che figata
no ce l'ho fatta no l'ho già fatta
grande a niente
roberta come faccio livella giu no con
la testa ci sono arrivato però non era
impossibile bisogna chiarire milano pare
così è veramente impossibile celebri
meglio la gallina dopo esplode occhio
esploso a far la sua fatta sito poi
anche cerioli si sono arrivati al
traguardo
ti aspetta un aspetto carifi qua si
prende se traguardo seguito alla gallina
del socialismo vice amo lo salvo no
no
e lo trova senza semplice non so perché
l'ho giova battaglia che semplice grande
ora prendi la gallina insieme 123 no no
la cinese cosa c ma non ci credo però
fossi morti aspettato perché credevo
fossi morto dai sei un bravo giocatore
ma bravi giocatori non avevano mai privi
di frassino
grazie mille va bè ragazzi cos'era va
bene dentro e consumi fatemi sapere se
volete un altro episodio ci sarà anche
sul suo canale uno di questi episodi
però i video vi sia piaciuto cose vive
ci sono come mi piace anche a rischio
cioè quello della descrizione sono state
insistenti e lanciate una testa dove ci
si vorrebbe ragazzi a un prossimo
episodio
[Musica]